well let's talk to the apprenticeship
and skills manager jillian keegan who
joins us now
good to see you this morning let's talk
about uh
a little bit of clarity on what's going
on with travel please
what is the latest
uh well actually the latest will be set
out by the transport minister on
thursday which is when the three-week
review comes
um but of course um you know what we're
trying to do is tread this careful
balance between opening up travel
but also keeping the country safe um so
i mean i know there's been a lot of
speculation in the press uh about what
uh the the
the system is going to be and obviously
we've explored many options but
effectively what we want to do is keep
it simple enough for people to really
understand
and obviously be able to take their own
decisions uh based on the system so we
have the red list countries the
uh ambalist uh countries and the green
list countries and the ambulance
countries if you're double vaccinated
you don't
have to self isolate and if you're not
double vaccinate
vaccinated than you do on your return
and in all of the systems
obviously you have to take pre-departure
tests and then a test on day two and
then there's additional tests and
additional quarantine in obviously for
red list
countries and you're only supposed to
come to redless countries if you're a
a british citizen or someone who's got a
writer residence here returning home
okay so what you seem to be indicating
there
is that amber plus is going which means
by the end of the week
presumably or the start of next week
france could be back on our travel list
well amber plus there is this one
category for france at the moment just
because of the concern over the beta
variant
but the transport secretary is next
review which is the three weekly review
he does uh every three weeks that's on
thursday this week
so he'll set out more um in terms of you
know what's happening with amber plus
and uh also with france in particular
see what what is
confusing is you say that you know
having a simplified system
is better for us because it allows us to
make a more informed choice as to what
we want to do which is exactly what
uh the minister matt warman said to me
yesterday about the idea of having
amber watch countries he said that is
providing more information it gives a
direction of travel for people to know
what is happening with a particular
country that they want to go to
and therefore they can make a better
more informed decision
you seem to be the government's rowing
back on that
well not really i mean obviously we're
exploring more options and every option
but the reality is
we're trying to tread this careful
balance and it is a careful balance
between opening up travel when we know
that there are
variants and and they're popping up in
different ways in different
countries and we know obviously there's
different case rates in different
countries as well so we are trying to be
as open as possible to travel but also
to keep people safe and that is a
difficult balance
there's no doubt it's a difficult
balance and we see countries all over
the world actually
you know putting different countries on
various lists as they all try to
navigate the balance
um but you know we're very um you know
obviously delighted with our vaccine
program
and we want to make sure that people can
benefit from that but at the same time
we are also concerned about new variants
there's no you know no doubt about that
so we're just trying to make sure that
we can
navigate that but it isn't easy to do
and
you know it's not as simple as we'd all
like as we're trying to navigate that
but you know we clearly want to open up
travel
um but also you know forgive me i mean
you're quite right and i'm sure
everybody agrees it's not simple and
it's not straightforward because nothing
has been with this pandemic but a
minister
this time yesterday telling me you know
we needed a watch list because it gives
people more clarity
today you're saying well we don't need a
watch list because it's all about giving
people
clarity and an ease of of choice
no wonder people think this is confusing
and chaotic
well maybe they better wait till the
government actually announces what it's
going to do as opposed to the
speculation that's
something i would definitely advise and
as i say the the transport secretary
will be
laying out on thursday but you know
there's no doubt that we are exploring
all options and getting that balance
between you know
giving people enough notice and warning
but also making it so that
it's simple enough it's difficult to do
you know i was out at the weekend and i
was asking people just generally did
they understand it
and it is difficult and people had
different interpretations so
you know that is a difficult balance but
i i think instead of spread
you know all speculation we will lay out
very very clearly
and of course on every three weeks the
transport secretary updates us
in terms of countries and which
countries are on which list
so this still leaves the possibility
then does it that the country could
switch
without any prior warning now if there's
going to be no watch list
could could switch from from amber to
red while you're out there so still no
guarantees of a a safe holiday if we can
put it in those terms
well obviously the transport secretary
will be setting out all of
you know the considerations on thursday
but you know i think there's no doubt
that you know we know that the pandemic
can change we know that the variance can
move we've actually
experienced that twice ourselves you
know christmas was
you know very much curtailed as we dealt
with the alpha variant and then
obviously
the general restrictions and removal of
restrictions was also delayed
as we were hit with the delta variant so
we know that these variants can hit
countries
and they can hit them in many ways what
we're really delighted with here is that
the vaccine program
looks as though it is providing a lot of
protection the case rates are coming
down we didn't know that that was going
to be the case when we
unlocked two weeks ago yesterday a lot
more of our
economy um but there's no doubt that
this
is a disease and the variance that you
know things can change very quickly
we've seen that we've seen that a number
of times ourselves
which is why the presumably the
government needs to be absolutely on the
ball with this
which raises the question what's
happening at the jbc
the the joint biosecurity center where
the the boss claire gardner
left her job without a successor being
appointed now that advises amongst other
things
on what to do about travel which
apparently what went back in june
still no appointment to replace that
that the jbc's left rudderless isn't it
i don't think so i mean these things are
you know as we've seen with many of
these committees
but it's a group of experts that are
looking at data that are giving
their analysis based on the data so you
know there's still a team of experts of
course we want to replace
uh the chair but you know there are
these team of experts that are still
looking at the data and giving their
analysis based on that
talking of confusion what about the app
i mean because
in terms of u-turns we're now told that
actually the
the um the test and trace app and the
the the way people get pinged on it is
going to be
scaled down made less sensitive
if you like which is what the government
said it wasn't going to do a couple of
weeks ago well look you know
everything's evolving i mean this is a
public health decision um so they've
been looking at the cases you know we
only
two weeks ago uh yesterday is when we
lifted a lot of restrictions in our
country as the delta case rates were
still going
up and now we've got a lot more data in
and they're looking at that data all the
time
it's not a u-turn we're dealing with a
global pandemic it is evolving
as we get more data and of course the
data is looking very favorable at the
moment so
public health have made that decision
they've decided
to remove welter to change it from five
days to two days
it's still when it's the most infectious
period the two days but five days was
you know even more cautious and they
have been cautious all along that's
their job their public health
um so you know they have to be cautious
but they've now looked at the data and
decided now is the time
to review that decision and you know
it's their decision and they've
um they've given us that information and
that's fantastic news i mean you know
every one of us you can understand the
people have them
we know it's we know it's only a week on
monday
that that people aren't going to have to
isolate at all in most cases
if they're pings so why not just bring
that forward
well because the whole reason that date
was set which is august the 16th which
was give us
enough time for all of our young people
to have the chance to be double
vaccinated that's why that date was set
because it wouldn't be fair to say
if your double vaccinated you don't need
to isolate if you haven't given them
the chance to be double vaccinated so
that was a deliberate date
so we're urging everybody please get the
vaccine and
you know if you if you started when you
were first offered it then you could be
double jabbed
by that date that is why we chose that
date and it's it's important that we're
we're fair to young people as well to
give them time to
get double vaccinated before we start to
have systems which
um are different for those that are
double vaccinated and those that aren't
and in terms of getting double
vaccinated what about getting
vaccination centers
onto university campuses that
universities are calling for
and we're getting reports either 170 000
unused doses that could expire soon
because there's been this sort of
comparatively low uptake amongst the
under 30s
that would be a sensible move wouldn't
it
well we're working with universities and
there's a lot of comms going out at the
moment to encourage young people
to go and and get the job and actually
the ons survey did show that many
of our young people 90 i think said they
were likely or fairly likely to get the
job but of course
they haven't yet got round to it we're
working with universities to make sure
that that you know those comms
are those messages are are there and
people are encouraged to take the
vaccine
as soon as possible we will also i mean
in my local area we are setting up for
freshers week
uh we're opening up our vaccination
center which is very close to the
university
for longer hours so that we can deal
with that and encouraging
young people who haven't yet been double
vaccinated to start the vaccination
process so we will work with
universities we will do
what's sensible and of course you know
there are i mean
thousands of uh free appointments so
anybody listening if they're if they're
if they're up and listening and they
haven't had their job yet you can very
easily get
a walk-in now and get your first
vaccination and we would encourage
everybody
to do that okay i mean talking about
those young people who
don't go to university i know you're
unveiling a a new scheme to try to help
these
flexible apprenticeships but it's it's
seven million pounds worth of funding
well
in the great scheme of things how many
people can that actually help
well in the great scheme of things we
actually spend 2.5 billion pounds a year
on apprenticeships but what we're trying
to do now is to make
apprenticeships more widely available in
some
sectors where they found it difficult to
work with the apprenticeship system
specifically because you have to offer
somebody a job
for a year and sometimes they they work
on contracts or they work in project
bases
so particularly the creative industries
for example we've been working with them
to make sure that they can access
apprenticeships they're really keen to
get more apprentices and
and access a wide diverse pool of talent
all across the country
and this will enable uh many to do that
and also smaller and medium
companies to make it easier to have an
apprenticeship that works on a number of
different projects across a number of
different
companies but but still a high quality
training offer